for the biggest racing circuit in the
world is coming to Las Vegas next year
the plans for fans are starting to
unfold Sports director Chris Matthews
joining us live along the world famous
strip with more Acres
hey Christian thank you very much I
appreciate that hey this is where
drivers will be making their moves on
that course this is turn nine of the 3.8
mile course you can see behind me right
here now some are saying this could be
the most important turn on the entire
course because right here is where some
drivers they have a chance perhaps to
overtake another driver just right here
on turn nine so it's going to be
interesting now no some of you are
saying how y'all want to be there for
this big race coming up in 2023 this may
be the most expensive ticket in Las
Vegas sports history and could be the
biggest single event ever held in Las
Vegas they're anticipating 400
000 fans now to put that in perspective
it would break the New Year's Eve
numbers on the Strip by nearly 100 000
people a ticket pre-registration portal
went online this morning which allows
you then to sign up for a ticket
pre-sale event this fall now in Miami
they had a similar event and 250 000
signed up for tickets so you'd expect
Las Vegas the Grand Prix here to be even
bigger and more popular
we're going to have a huge menu for this
Chris it's gonna it's probably gonna
surpass anything you've ever seen for a
Nascar event you can't even compare the
two uh but we'll have Pages probably a
booklet of propositions for the F uh one
uh series when they uh ride into town
oh it's gonna be so big we don't even
know the ticket prices yet but here are
the top three prices for grandstand
seats number one Monaco 700 each then
Miami at 650 then Great Britain at 400 a
piece some of the prices at the other
shops uh around the world a little bit
more reasonable between 120 and 175
remember these aren't even the secondary
ticket prices hey if you go to the Las
Vegas F1 site it is called uh you can
pre-register at the Las Vegas Grand Prix
Foundation you can pre-register and you
also make a donation to help feed the
Homeless are open to feed about a
million people here in the Las Vegas
Valley and your donation is
7.77 that's a jackpot number right here
in Las Vegas they wouldn't do it any
other way reporting along the world
famous Las Vegas strip I'm Chris
Matthews eight Sports now thank you
Chris 400 000 fans quite an event yeah
it's gonna be huge